when I was growing up in China my dad
and I used to play this game we would
memorize classic Chinese poems and texts
and we were recite it together and try
to finish each other's sentences
and there's one that I remember so
dearly it's called the three character
Classics and the first phrase goes
people at Birth are inherently good and
those six letters has such a great
impact on me when I was a kid and I
still truly believe them today
I have always found goodness in the
people I met everywhere I went in the
world this is for anyone
who have the faith and the courage to
hold on to the goodness in themselves
and to hold on to the goodness in each
other no matter how difficult is to do
that
and this is for you you inspire me to
keep going
thank you thank you